yeah about me I guess first let me go
back ah yeah interesting title there's
no actual hacking involved it was all
legal and I gave myself permission to
read my own Gmail but hacking sounds
interesting like I'm gonna crack into
your Gmail but I'm not you can do it
yourself so I don't know Jarett plan
this but Roger before me and Stephanie
after me or Hopkins people and I'm a
Hopkins grad so you get a nice Hopkins
afternoon
I guess they breed our people there and
like Kathryn earlier I got here by
talking to Jarrod mistakenly and he saw
something I did and said you should
present that and that was like okay and
that was months ago and he remembered so
I'm here but yeah so about me yeah I
raised chickens that's a view from my
chicken cam when I get chicks in the
spring y'all can get in on the live feed
it's great chicken cuteness action
I hate pie charts which I assume the
rest of you do raise your hand if you
hate pie charts alright those of you
without your hands up
talk to me after and my my real job now
is I find people doing DNS tunneling
kind of things cyber stuff so when you
all sign into the Wi-Fi today you got
that so did you all instead higher up
your DNS VPN network to your own DNS
machine probably not just me but you
could have an got free internet so
next time I'll bring my burner laptop
will have a different presentation but
yeah so now a confession I spoke at the
New York our conference in 2017 that's
me there looking angry because I'm an
angry person
and I talked about data privacy and how
the lawyers are gonna come and ruin your
analytics by you know things like the
GDP are and you can't have data so you
can't analyze data and I was probably a
little ahead of my time there because
people are like what and then afterwards
during these great sessions a lot of
people came up to me it was like so I
totally released data and I probably
shouldn't have am I going to jail and
I'm like not yet good glad you're not in
Europe but you know my big secret there
was that I wasn't on our person right I
I was just like a math nerd and was a
Python guy and I was asked to speak at
this hour conference and I was like to
my CEO what are you doing like I I'm not
that guy he's like you know I have to
talk about art just talk about data
privacy and our people like data so
that's what I did and it was
nerve-racking and I was like I don't
like art in fact I was kind of anti are
in fact I was like this guy I was like
are is a programming language written by
a statistician like who thought that was
a good idea nobody it's a big joke on
the world but I said at that conference
and and it started to sink in which was
good so I kind of made an effort over
the last you know two years or so to to
really learn and embrace our and I and I
found out at that conference really that
our had changed right so I had like that
one course in grad school at Hopkins
that you know we had to use our and I
was like okay I wrote a bunch of arrows
and I was like what's the point of all
this I don't get it
give me my grade and I'm done and I'll
never touch it again until a couple
years ago so but it changed right that's
what I learned and I hope you all have
learned this the go read the tidy paper
which is I guess pre tidy verse but
whenever it kind of kind of put words to
how I now think about data and probably
how I should have been thinking about
data and even change like how I think
about big data like you know big
unstructured sequel became the big thing
and just like well it's actually tied a
tidy data but it just has a bunch of
anaise all throughout it you don't have
to worry about him right you know and
then they they came up with this funky
pipe thing and the tidy verse and and
can I always hooked and the other thing
that happened at that conference that
that has happened here I hope for for
most people is this format like we got
20 minutes to talk I can talk for 20
minutes about anything
in fact I'm fluent in Pig Latin
I could talk for 20 minutes in pig latin
and and you can be at the bar later
we'll do piglet but yeah but this
community is great right you've got 20
minutes and we've got these big breaks
and and ingeras good at it getting nerds
to force themselves to talk to each
other and then it turns out we're we're
all kind of have little quirk things
like speaking pig latin and we get along
so yeah this community is great right so
anyone this is like get on Twitter and
start following everyone you you've seen
speak in her and around and talked about
right
you'll get great this was great
conversation in this whole thread we
could do a whole speech on it I still
don't know you know what the real
difference is between equal in in that
arrowy thing but I am NOT a cop so I
don't use equal but seriously like like
joining us great stuff
everyone's helpful Jared has a slack if
you even mentioned that today no get on
get on his slack and and and ask
questions and don't really you know post
a cool plot you made because you'll be
up here like me
so unless that's what you want so yeah
back to the real talk
so before I my other talk was about data
privacy techniques and differential
privacy is kind of like the main the
main thing in that now and the new 2020
census
lots of census talk they're actually
releasing that data in 2020 using
differential privacy so what does that
mean this is this is the formula it's
all self-evident I'm sure I can go on
but I'll go over it so differential
privacy is really if you have two data
sets and you perform some kind of
aggregation or operation on those two
data sets the result of that operation
shouldn't differ by more than this e to
the epsilon and epsilon is what
differential privacy people call their
privacy budget and so the Census and the
technique to do this generally is you
submit a query to a data source and then
you get the result of that query and
then you add noise proportional to the
data or what what's specific
specifically the query was about so in
the census there will be a lot of
counting their their their sensitivity
is what what they say drives that and
when you count things your sensitivity
is one so it's you know an off by one
error you will never be able to like
zero in on someone specifically with the
with the new census data if they do
differential privacy right I hope they
did I've seen them talking and yeah so
that so the new data will have noise in
it add another noise term to your models
I don't think it's going away so you can
learn more about privacy and data
privacy this this talk isn't really
about data privacy there's this Harvard
privacy tools project which has kind of
started to be this you know despite it
not being Hopkins it's not it seems to
be a good spot for data privacy
professionals to collaborate they have
MIT and a bunch of other people there
they claim they're putting an R package
out I haven't seen it yet but I know
they are a bunch of our people and and
I'm sure they're busy like the rest of
us and haven't done a good thing yet
quite yet but look for it in the future
so yeah then when I'm in the midst of
all this data privacy stuff like this
happened right the Facebook and
Cambridge analytic so everyone knows
what happened you had to know that you
know if your first girlfriend was a
Sagittarius you were gonna have a happy
marriage later in life took a quiz they
stole your data and you know whatever
happened happened after that with your
data so you know with that I was like
all right cool
Google Alerts I have Google Alert set up
for differential privacy this is my
Google Alert for multiple sclerosis
another favorite topic but basically you
set up keywords and you get articles
about that keywords semi periodically
when they find it I mean if you if you
put a a too broad of a keyword you get a
email every day with all kinds of stuff
but something like differential privacy
that you kind of get in periodically so
when that Cambridge thing went down I
was like oh cool I have I think now
different for privacy is coming into my
Google Alerts more and more let me see
if I can figure that out so in my new
are hat because I went to the New York
our conference I I did just that
so I blindly dug in and I said how do I
read email and our and I knew Jared like
sends emails and ours you guys get our
email from Jared for this whole
conference I'm sure if you look at the
bottom and I was like alright I can do
this and if you go to take out Google
calm you can just download your whole
mailbox or parts of your mailbox or
actually anything in the Google verse
that is your data they will tar it up
and send it to you so cool Duke go do
that and download it and
so this TM is text mining there you go
and they have a male plug in and you
kind of plug in your inbox file Google
send you and you do a V corpus and I was
like this is feeling like old-school
R and then your thing looks like
old-school junk like heavy a raw email
is just text all over the place it's a
bunch of like all your attachments are
just encoded into text and it's it's a
nightmare system that it actually still
works is amazing but I was like this
that I started to parse through this all
the blank lines and figuring out what
they use as carriage returns and it
depends who sent you the email what the
uses carriage returns big nightmare
so yeah in typical art fashion I found
another package so Gmail or Gmail are
awesome it interfaces with the Gmail
REST API so I hope you use Gmail because
otherwise the rest of this will kind of
be useless so there's a bunch of set up
kind of required to authorize and go
through the OAuth and create a project
and stuff and it's not that hard the
Gmail our site goes through that pretty
good go to the github explain it oh but
then you just get a bunch of functions
that are really easy and then really
work well with with deep liar and the
tidy verse and all that like just
message gives you a bunch of message IDs
with a query string so and then you just
pass in those message IDs to other
functions like subject and from and all
that stuff and it just starts ripping
apart your your email for you in a nice
kind of our fashion there's still some
quirks to it but in general is pretty
good
so here is my my little simple program
but yeah basically you just get the
secret file from Google that they give
you when you go through the whole setup
and load it in
and then you just get messages and this
is a simple query string like you can
type in Gmail search and what what I'm
looking for here is is this line of text
in the email with I'm actually looking
for this number so I wrote a little you
know jisub thing to grab sometimes it
says news sometimes it says web whatever
grab it
grab the number and oh hydrate message
list this is not that it is grabbing the
body of the message after you get the
IDS but once you do that you can grab
that number out of these emails and
start seeing if people care about
privacy so this is the cumulative number
of Google Alert articles in my email and
then Cambridge analytic a hit and we got
a spike later on the GDP are hit and
nobody cared so I guess Europeans don't
write articles or whatever but I was I
was hoping for another spike but but no
so that's about it there's still some
quirks in our you know what package is
the function tidy in its in the broom
package it's not in tidy burst it's not
in the tidy package it's in broom
whatever it's fine you should get used
to it how do you find the right packages
Crayons searcher i like if you guys seen
crayon searcher well like probably can't
pull it up without screwing this whole
system up but it's built into our studio
and you just kind of search around cran
for the right package and sort by one it
was published which is the most useful
thing probably lately I feel like there
should be a crayon ooh or something like
some kind of flag like it works with
deep liar or it kind of was before that
but people are writing packages to wrap
those packages all the time so yeah so
the other thing I like to do is play the
art game if I can guess the package so
paste is kind of Kluck clunky and you're
kind of looking for something else well
it's glue right because our people are
clever so
the package you are looking forward to
replace paste is glue and yeah so if
you're looking for something you know
this is really how I kind of learned our
was by analyzing myself like I just
started downloading all my own data
here's a links to go download all your
own data from all the major platforms
and you'll get a nice zip file and stuff
like that of everything and you can
usually select what you want like if you
want every image or not and just go go
to it and start ripping through it with
our and I I find that to be a more
interesting way than then you know
trying to understand empty cars or why
people care about that so much well I
mean really you have to understand that
to learn are so yeah reach out to me
that's me and I think that's all I have
[Music]
[Applause]